übrigens läutet die neue task force von
bisher 20 ja da kam jetzt ganz neue
herausforderungen vor allem mit der
rückkehr der wehrpflicht wir testen
gerade ob das mit den 18 jährigen von
heute überhaupt noch gehen würde ich
muss sagen der erste eindruck ist gar
nicht mal so schlecht so jungs
beziehungsweise junge also marius wie
wir es geübt haben du tust jetzt so als
sei das eine scharfe mine und du hast
genau eine minute zeit sie zu
entschärfen
fokussiertes arbeiten unter druck kann
diese generation das überhaupt noch es
heißt ja immer sie hätten so eine kurze
aufmerksamkeitsspanne
die ganze spiel klavier
wobei das mit der wehrpflicht ist ja
erst mal nur ein gedankenspiel die
eigentliche baustelle ist das mit der
beschaffung hier zum beispiel lagern wir
unsere aktuellen munitionsvorräte kurzer
inventur eine patrone
zwei patronen ja
ja der kollege der schreibt den ganzen
tag verzweifelte mails als
beschaffungsamt in koblenz und falls
irgendwer glaubt ja da geht es um
fehlende panzer oder hubschrauber
schön wär's viele soldaten tragen bei
übungen wie dieser ihre eigenen
wintersachen auch das walkie talkie ist
privat das einzige vom gerät ist seit
monaten kaputt ich hab die schnauze
derartig voll was ich rufe jetzt selber
einfach in gruppen zusammen
problems
kann man schämt sich ja nur noch für
diesen gurken verein hier wann soll das
denn endlich mal besser werden wann
dafür haben wir ja einen
entwicklungsplan aufgelegt bis in das
jahr 2030 etwas früher sollte vielleicht
warme unterwäsche geliefert werden denn
sind daran fehlt es
liebe zuschauer öffnen sie ihr herz und
machen sie mit beim winterhilfswerk
bundeswehr stricken für die truppe jede
warme unterhosen
bundeswehr wir würden deutschland
blieben aber wieder
so kinder ich hoffe die kamera läuft
denn ich halte nicht an abonniert den
kanal hier danke euer gernot hassknecht
so ich gehe wieder nach hause
schönen feierabend jürgen